jess i don't
i sold taryn i'm sorry
hey what
right yes
[Music]
jess did it she officially ended her
relationship with colt
after he sent nudes to multiple women
and revealed
vanessa was staying at his house i done
with code forever
i don't want to caught you with my life
caught stress man
not men enough
after calling it quits just did not
hesitate
to meet up with the woman who once
referred to colt as
a demon and a geeky player
what say good morning my good afternoon
my good night my
friend was a big deal right
i am sure larissa enjoyed every bit of
that conversation
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
the truth literally sets some of the
couples free
on the latest episode of happily ever
after
what are they talking about tell us your
side of the story did you get forced off
the police force
elizabeth's family has continued to
press andre
about his past so for the sake of having
his moldovan wedding
he finally revealed his deep dark
secret yes i was four years old left yes
i'll give you the full update on that in
just a few but first
let's circle back to colt and jess after
she walked out on him
and left his door open colt decided
he needed a drink at this point my
relationship with jess
i know it's over there's no point in
trying to fix it
i most definitely was not a good
boyfriend to jess i've made so many
mistakes it's going to take a long time
for me to reflect and
process everything
[Music]
ever since my divorce i've tried to make
a better cult
but i've just made things worse
i feel like i don't know who i am
anymore
i just feel a tiny bit of sympathy for
coal
just a tiny bit okay just a little
and there's someone who doesn't feel any
sympathy for colt at all
and that someone is larissa the next day
jess reached out to her to meet up for
drinks
it's a little bit complicated to see my
ex
husband girlfriend because she didn't
listen when i warned her
about a coach jessica coate is a demo
he's a player he's a geeky player
you know once he he doesn't need you
anymore
he's gonna try to do the same that he
did to me
so
last night i broke with coats
larissa's face is saying a lot
right now just went ahead and told her
that she was
basically right about cole and his
play-aways
remember you say he could have a lot of
girls
yeah it's true 80 girls in the
screenshot for me
in my social media i don't know i feel
like he wants to be a pink
[Music]
god say good morning my good afternoon
good night my
oh this tiny first michael has a big
deal right
after they kiki'd about that jess
brought up
vanessa and apparently
she was also an issue in larissa and
colt's relationship
yes vanessa is the woman that was buying
group home for coach
what a long time ago
she bugged a groupo and said merry
christmas
i thought it would make you relax so
crazy
i described coty as a player
because when i was married to cody i
found that a woman named vanessa
bugged to him a group home so might
vanessa
was with colt since we were married
can cole and vanessa just be together
can they make that happen can we do that
because at this point
i'm just tired of hearing his women
complain about her
i know he said she's not really into him
but
something needs to happen all right
before jess and larissa ended their
lunch date
larissa made sure to show jess some love
which
i thought was really nice of her but you
know jesus you are beautiful and sweetie
you have big boobies
so god is nothing
my fear today is better because i see
his problems not me and colt
this problem is cold i think larissa is
good person
and she stuck with i me a new friend now
thank you coach oh
women supporting women you gotta love it
all right our final musty moment goes to
andre
who after weeks of back and forth
finally revealed to elizabeth's family
why he was forced out of moldova
okay so listen to this the corruption
here makes
people do a lot of stuff okay so when
you're in a police
you have to close eyes sometimes and you
have to go along okay
you're working for somebody when we on
his higher rank so you have to execute
the worders and you don't if you say no
they're going to try to set you up
so i got a setup of some stuff and after
this i said no i'm not going to do that
anymore and i just
left somebody tried to frame you exactly
andre went on to explain how corruption
in his country is really bad especially
in the police force
according to him you either play the
game and break the law
or you choose to get out and he chose to
get out
what if he would have stayed instead of
left what would it happen i don't know
it may be between maybe i would ride a
hundred thousand dollar car or maybe i
was in jail
so it could have went either way exactly
when you work like uh
eight hours per week uh job when you're
getting paid 250 dollars max yeah
you see what's going on so because
you're getting that amount per month
it sounds like the people here almost
feel like they have to be corrupt
because there's no other choice
good logic jen elizabeth's brother
charlie still doesn't think andre's
being a hundred percent truthful
and based off of our glimpse of the
wedding next week
these two my bump heads once again
i think it was uh expensive my dad
has like seven kids it's like why are
you doing this for him
andre you're our family now and we love
you
[Music]
okay i spoke to andre and elizabeth
not too long ago and i had to ask andre
why can't you and charlie just get along
here's what he had to say it's a work
relationship again
it's just like it's just stepping in and
uh
you know like he's uh protecting his
relationship
in a work relationship you know like
it's just he's protecting his power all
the time and
you know like he has his own views and i
have mine and
that's why he just like these things
happen andrei
and charlie are two alpha males and so
that doesn't always
work when we're in like family events
because
they're trying to be louder than one
another and like you know just like have
the last word and
sometimes it doesn't always mesh well
together yeah
that's been very clear well elizabeth
looked beautiful and i can't wait to see
how
the wedding is going to play out alright
90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you